hi friends my guest this week is Rory
Sutherland
the vice chairman of oral-b advertising
now before most podcasts start there's a
little bit of foreplay backwards and
forwards between myself and the guest
catching up and talking about what we're
going to talk about and stuff like that
with Rory it was more analogous to me
trying to step onto a train going
high-speed and he's just he just began
so I started recording straightaway also
Rory had a British Gas technician come
round to sort out his boiler partway
through so you will go through the
adventure that is Rory's boiler plus all
of the amazing things that we spoke
about today he is an absolute master of
behavioral economics and the psychology
of advertising anyone who has ever
bought anything in a shop should listen
to this podcast I'm not going to
pontificate anymore because it's it's
just fantastic
enjoy
[Music]
I would I would regard consumer
capitalism as kind of the Galapagos
Islands of understanding human
motivation because just as evolution
throws up things the duck-billed
platypus the kangaroo etc that don't
really make much sense in the same way
consumer capitalism is interesting both
the things which shouldn't be successful
but are and the classic example that is
red bull but I mean you could actually
if you think about some of the greatest
business successes of the last 10 20 30
years I mean going back further denim
freeze-up doesn't really make sense as a
fabric the popularity of denim doesn't
make any sense he kind of fades it looks
a bit [ __ ] it was manufactured as a
wagon cover and then worn as overalls by
indigent laborers you know you would
have expected silk to have become big
yeah and the trouser front but nope it's
not silk its jeans then you've got
things again you know if you've made a
business case for Wikipedia and your
last slide and said and the best thing
is that everybody's going to write this
for free okay basically you would have
been shown out of the room it's
completely insane
Red Bull again doesn't taste very nice
cost a fortune becomes in a tiny cap you
know no one making a case for that
really would get anywhere you know one
Oh in a Soviet controlled economy no one
would have sat down with a you know the
Supreme Soviet and said well for our
next seven-year plan what the Union of
Soviet Socialist Republics really needs
is Nova Price disgusting tasty drink but
at the same time I think it's
interesting because I think what
capitalism and evolution does is it
throws up in it bonkers successes but
there are also things that fail that
logically shouldn't I mean in the case
of in the case of say evolution why is
pathogenesis or wires in other words
asexual reproduction so very rare yeah
because if you want to replicate 100
percent of your genes simply splitting
into two is a you would think it's a
pretty
a system with this sex stuff you only
need one of you right yeah exactly and
off you go
what seems to happen is that you where
the disease hits you all die
so set Nonna's genetic variation sex is
the diversity trade-off that means that
some of your genes will survive
it's hedging your bets essentially and
some it's you know covering your bases
because you'd rather have your genes
survive split between a variety of
different carriers yeah then put all
your eggs in one basket and I think what
tends to happen is you do get these
asexual reproduction things happening
and they're very very successful right
up to the point where they aren't but
then when they fail they fail
spectacularly that is this might this
might be unfortunately birth is this a
man from British gasps oh I'm so sorry
it's very authentic Ponca absolutely
other podcast always being pause if you
like that we've paused right i'ma back
that was funny more about washbasins
they're finicky and and very fine-tuned
subtle sort of the device so I wanted to
talk about news article which I got sent
yesterday I can't believe that I've
never heard of this before but you may
have done have you heard of the
hit-to-kill phenomenon in China
no so oh is this this thing where it's
more expensive if you hit someone and
they survived it's it's more expensive
because you get sued yeah so if you hit
a person in China in the car you have to
pay the medical bills for a lifetime but
if you kill them you only pay once like
a burial fee so the fee for killing is
about thirty to fifty thousand dollars
but a lifetime of medical expenses is in
the excess of millions sometimes so
there's these bizarre videos where
drivers will hit someone and then
reverse backwards and forwards over the
body because it's more economical to
kill than it is to injured so you have I
don't know if you know that film
thx 1-1 3-8 but that's a very
George Lucas film but that's the kind of
world in which also perfect nipple job
in which you know that the whole of the
world is kind of controlled by
accountants from enough of course that's
true in the UK in that in the UK about
five years ago the insurance industry
was hit by a young male driver who
effectively plowed into a bus queue
leaving a large number of people
essentially critically injured and
disabled for life but not dead right and
I think the the total cost of the claim
came to something like 70 million pounds
from one accident Wow
now someone in the insurance industry
admitted to me that his head of it we
would have been considerably better off
if he'd actually killed them all
because patent lives industry now you've
simply got to trust the insurance in
this case not to send people round to
hospitals disconnecting life-support
systems and what would hope that that
doesn't happen but of course that that
very simple economic truth is true all
over the world that it's only in China
where presumably the people are
uninsured is that right I'm not sure
about that I think it I don't understand
why their insurance doesn't cover the
expenses of incident which is associated
with their insurance that have presumed
that's what the insurance would have
been therefore and we have to be careful
about this because of course we the
reason we have to be careful about this
is there's an element of prejudice which
is probably a bias which is we tend to
see the Chinese as slightly more
calculating or unemotional and then
there's a whole bunch of sort of
stereotyping going on there we've also
got to remember that of course the
proliferation of I mean I think the
Russians probably are pretty ship
drivers but my my impression of rough
Russian driving skills isn't helped by
the fact that dash cams are much more
common in the Soviet Union or were
historically or the early in Russia
rather than they are in the West and
therefore a disproportionate number
of those videos on YouTube showing
people driving in a bonkers fashion or
trashing supercars or driving out in
front of trains yeah a disproportionate
number of those are going to be Russian
simply because in Russia it seems to me
that having a dashcam sounded fitting is
just a standard fitting whereas I don't
have one I've always asked that
questions by the way what happens if you
go to dash cam and you make a terrible
mistake yourself just throw it out the
window you throw a little indoor trash
it or roll up drive over it oh yeah the
truck that unfortunately the dash cam
which logged the footage of me crashing
into someone was destroyed in the crash
as I crushed into someone ah right I
looked at buying a dashcam and so this
is a bit of a double-edged sword isn't
it you know because it's coming it's
gonna capture my road rage if I'm
swearing at the guy in front it's gonna
capture all that [ __ ] which you know
isn't necessarily gonna help me in a
court of law and who did occur to me
that a dashcam well you know maybe I'm
better off without one decide it's it's
hedging your bets there about whether or
not you think that you're going to be
the victim or the perpetrator of of
accidents more or less at the time I
suppose I mean it's a worrying thing in
a sense because he it is there's
something about that that's indicative
of a low load trust culture isn't there
yeah yeah I'd like to think I'm the kind
of person who regardless of the evidence
if it were my fault
I would you know I know we're always
told in a road accident you must never
apologize never admit blame because of
the legal implications but I'd like to
think if I ran into the back of someone
I'd basically say look fair and square
this is what happened yeah and I'd take
the hit and I'd like to think I'm that
kind of person and so the idea that
we're not we're in a society where you
know the assumption is that other people
are lying strikes me as a bit alarming
yeah I think you're trying to were
trying to protect for a few odd
situations where there's a little bit
the system goes awry so to speak with
that well they're the fake whiplash
claims on there which of course are so
in other words someone will break I mean
occasionally someone will drive in front
of you and then
Raik stupidly in order for you to go
into the back of them
there was families of people that were
doing that wasn't there driving across
in their slip planes and River and
stopping in front of lorries and stuff
like that
I'll tell you a very wonderful story
when she'll love which is very podcast
worthy which was I hasten to add a
friend of a friend of a friend but I
think it is actually true which is she
self as far as you he was driving her
extremely drunk and drove onto a large
roundabout in his way home and realized
that he'd overshot and missed the turn
now you'd think the beauty of a
roundabout to a sober person is that if
you miss your turning you can simply go
around again to the piste by parallel
this isn't immediately apparent and he
immediately slammed on the brakes and
started reversing back to the correct
turn off while reversing background the
roundabout he slammed into a car behind
and he was just about to basically leg
it when a police car turns up just at
the moment you don't want to turn up you
see and the police car just goes hold on
a second sir William just abandoned I'll
just go to speak to the driver behind
you he sees the policeman goes and
breathalyze the pad into whom he's
reversed
you see which to the cop is not an
irrational if someone's hit a car in
front you assume the car behind is too
plain and the breadth of lines of the
car behind comes up positive and the
policeman then simply walks up to his
window and says will you really better
go say so I'm terribly sorry that guy
behind completely after the fairies
[Laughter]
guardian angel so much serendipity there
well yeah that is thanking your lucky
stars situation isn't it yeah I want it
I want to move on to the most pressing
topic at hand which is the debate
between wet and dry toilet toilet paper
and whether or not you should have a B
day or the Arabic shut offer in your
house
well I'm fan of the [ __ ] offer and big
fan of the Japanese toilet I'm a big fan
of moist toilette paper
I mean see between my father who's 88
said the same thing that the whole
business between getting up in the
morning and leaving the house if you
consider the extraordinary improvement
in terms of time-saving that's brought
to us at other times in the day by
things like the dishwasher or need
online shopping if you choose to use it
or the washing machine all the
extraordinary entertainment made
possible by television that part of the
day has been transformed since my father
was born in 1930 ok since his own father
was born in about 1895 it's
unrecognizable and yet the first part of
the day nothing you know [ __ ] shave
shower basically nothing's happened we
still have a Victorian first half hour
of the day yeah we're primitive we
aren't totally primitive and it strikes
me that this is an area where there's
huge potential for innovation but you
know the reason my stylet paper also
fascinates me because it's one of those
things and the the immediate parallel is
what we're doing now which is video
conferencing it's one of those
technologies which should be big but
isn't and it seems very strange to
compare moist lavatory paper with video
we're doing right now yeah but both of
them you can make a fantastic logical
case ok so I mean I make the case for
moisture lavage of paper how come our
anus is the only part of the body which
we think it's adequate to clean with dry
paper I'm entirely with the Islamic
world on this one I'm with the Japanese
on it because you wouldn't go out into
your garden with some fairly harmless
earth potting some plants and you'd come
in and go look I've got mud on my hands
let me rub the very vigorously with cell
a4 printer paper to remove them up you'd
kind of use water wouldn't you ok
and the fact that we in the West you
consider ourselves so advanced cleaner
rectums with dry paper is ridiculous ok
you can just go out excuse people I
suppose you do it first thing in the
morning and then have a shower or bath
you could say ok that's something but I
mean this that Arabic tube thing is at
least a nod in the right direction I
found it a bit weird that you
occasionally get them I was in a prison
in Qatar a long story but they have the
tube but they don't have any toilet
paper which is a bit and I'd have
the problem that I've found so Yusuf who
is one of the co-hosts to the show he
recently purchased his first property
and one of the mandatory things that he
had to have ahead of a washer/dryer
combo was a shot offer in his in his
bathroom but the problem is that it's
right next to the boiler so the water
pressure that comes out if you don't
have if you're not able to hold
sufficient anal tone and ring tension
you end up accidentally giving yourself
an enema with your irrigation through
reverse cuz I'm having my bathroom at
home later on this yeah so I think I
will consider one of those because I
agree with you I think it's barbaric
that we don't have them and actually
very strange actually two things one of
the things I often talk to my dad about
this my dad's 88 so you have this very
interesting contrast I also buy gadgets
for my dad to see whether he uses them
or not as a kind of experiment because
I'm the kind of idiot okay he'll buy any
old [ __ ] you know I've bought yogurt
makers bread makers I bought any bloody
gadget but I can simply cuz i enjoy its
intrinsic gadget hamas yeah and so i was
find interesting buying my dad things
because what he likes and what he
doesn't is revealing as to what's
genuinely useful i think i think at the
age of 88 you you've got a fairly
sensible take on what's life improving
and what is it i bought one of the
Google home pod minis which is like
elect sense like the echo doctor of the
Google equivalent and I wrote about this
in The Spectator a few people said what
the hell are you doing plugging you know
Amazon and Google's products as does if
they need any help my argument for this
was that mostly those products being
sold as ways to turn on your lights
remotely control your thermostat now I
do all that [ __ ] because I'm weird okay
my argument was that 30 spectator reader
or your spectator readers mum and dad in
their 70s or 80s it's a technology none
of those people will buy off their own
back there's not a chance in hell that
buddy NJT is gonna wander into curries
PC world and go get me an Amazon echo
dot or a home pod mini yeah actually
it's if you think about it in pensioner
terms it's the world's best radio for 30
quid yeah okay it'll play any music you
want you just asked for it it'll play
any radio station you want it'll tell
you the time it'll tell you the weather
it'll tell you how to cook a turkey so
30 quid for the ability to speak to a
supercomputer interesting my dad I only
installed it on about 27th of December
but he used it about you know six or
seven times a day really brilliantly
after I wrote that article a friend of
mine told me that his mum is in a
nursing home where they bought an echo
dot and they put it in the lounge of the
nursing home now I think this is a
brilliant I don't know no one's ever
thinking and no one's got a position a
tech product as it's perfect for oldies
okay because it's kind of the kiss of
death in marketing terms you know it's
rather like I bought from a company
which only sells products to the elderly
and disabled I bought I'd want a
long-handled dustpan and brush right so
it's a dustpan with a really long handle
and a brush with a really long handle
which means you don't have to grovel on
the floor when you've tipped some
conflicts okay now it's a brilliant
product for the disabled but it's also a
pretty brilliant product for anybody who
isn't just say yeah it's the firm yet
it's not sexy isn't it actually there's
I mean this is one of those interesting
questions in tech which is how come we
put a man on the moon
before we thought of putting wheels on
luggage I mean genuinely you know if you
think of the level of genius required
okay
between those two those two enterprises
it was literally long after we'd had a
bad laughter we'd had you know
tranquillity base etc someone thought
well this luggage stuff actually most of
the weight could actually be borne by
the floor and using a wheel which is not
an unfamiliar adventure you know now
okay I'm sure that what's happened
partly is that sideline tent like
skateboard inline wheels
became more and more affordable as a
by-product perhaps of skateboarding or
something of that kind yeah that the
technology somehow improved nevertheless
you could have had a basic wheels you
could have been something something
beforehand so are you saying
weirdly that giving products to
pensioners is kind of like the litmus
test Occam's razor canary in the
coalmine for whether or not a pensioners
don't generally they're not doing things
to show off or you know they're low on
signaling and they're high on pragmatism
and practicality and the other thing I
bought my dad which was an extraordinary
success the Philips airfryer that's a
it's a guy it's actually technically
it's not a fryer it's a super it's a
small desktop fan of them where he last
superheated air and you can cook chips
or cook any food think of it as halfway
between an oven and a microwave and
you've got about the right thing now I
bought one myself and I thought it was
an absolute game changer and I thought
well maybe this is just because of my
inherent teton philia so near philia I
bought mums my dad who's become a weird
air fryer evangelist going around
various other old people that's right
frying [ __ ] pointing this out and
actually to the other people's credit
they do actually occasionally people
come up to here at the pub and go that
air fryer that was a good tip nice about
yeah I think I think designing for the
disabled or designing for the elderly is
inherently interesting because I've
written about this in The Spectator cos
in a sense if you take for example
wheelchair wraps when wheelchair ramps
are also useful to people with wheels
luggage okay the legislation that
replaces doorknobs with door handles is
designed people who don't have use of
their hands who can open a door with an
elbow rather than needing a hand now
what you can remember it and likewise
the reason that the shampoo opens at the
top and the conditioner at the bottom I
think was designed for partially sighted
people the case but it's a good
principle because in the shower you're
partially sighted I mean if you wear
spectacles you're not wearing them in
the shower if you are you can't see a
[ __ ] thing
I don't wear spectacles ice
something in the shower that's unless
someone really mean comes in and turns
the shampoo then then you take the fact
of say the doorknob well if you're
carrying two mugs of tea you effectively
haven't got the use of your hands so
actually most humans are partially
disabled inside this came from BT
brought out this huge buttoned phone
which was designed for people who are
significantly visually impaired and that
weirdly to their surprise it became
their best-selling non what will you say
wired telephone and firstly this is a
bedside phone you've got people who
haven't of their specs on they're
probably reaching over and lying on one
side so they want to be able to dial by
taps rather than by sight and designing
for the extremes is always interesting
and I think that you know don't get me
wrong I don't blame them for marketing
Alexa as a kind of leading edge tech
thing but the reason I wrote the article
in The Spectator is the application for
anybody over the age of 60 and bear in
mind no one over the age of 60 is gonna
buy that thing so what I wanted people
do is buy it for all the people as a
Christmas present now the wonderful
thing is my friend's mother who's in the
nursing home she's a big Ray Charles fan
and she gets to the lounge first and she
says Alexa play Ray Charles and off the
Ray Charles goes she won't use the Alexa
whether there's anybody else in the room
because she doesn't want the other old
secret to know how it works because
they'll have to put up with their [ __ ]
music so she actually uses a lecture at
a fantastic 30 away yeah where she'll
never actually change the volume or
change the music while there's anybody
else present yep ladies the leading
ignorance the same I don't know it just
plays Ray Charles Ray Charles machine
Ray Charles or Mahalia Jackson it's it's
a special radio that plays nothing else
yeah you're totally right it seems like
designing for the extremes with this
kind of super utilitarian approach where
you've got the absolute no frills and
everything so as a perfect example we
are
shoehorn evangelists on this show anyone
who doesn't have a
shoehorn is losing some skin at a rate
that is completely destructive when your
shoes by scuffing them as you put them
in AB snow I totally agree with you on
that the shoehorn is again and actually
the long handle dustpan and brush which
I bought from a disabled supply is place
that again is obviously every dustpan
and brush should be like that yeah and
so there's an interesting question which
is I mean there's a wider question here
which is are things which are easy sort
of stigmatized or devalued and so
videoconferencing fascinates me because
our business is reluctant to adopt it
simply because it is comfortable
pleasant and you can do it from home so
is there this sort of macho singling
which is no know if it's a serious
business meeting you get up at six
o'clock in the morning you fly to
Frankfurt and that what we're doing is
we're signalling commitment through
effort now that wouldn't matter if the
effort were actually beneficial an
example of a technology that just as
evolution leads to brilliant things
which work fantastically which none of
us would ever have thought of but it
also leads to dumb runaway what's called
fishy Aryan runaway of the Peacocks tail
okay where you get effectively run away
arms races between different males say
to attract female attention
it was occurred to me that the
typewriter as a technology was
emblematic of that in that it meant that
for a period the word processor
different matter because you can take
[ __ ] edit it you know change the
addressee you know you don't have to
type the same thing 47 times WordPress
is a different thing but the typewriter
essentially meant that for a period in
about a hundred years everything
produced by a serious business had to be
written twice and then if it needed
anything because I'm just about old
enough to remember when you'd get [ __ ]
type C at work it was only really the
first two or three years of work where
you'd hand write a memo and your PA
would type it up and distribute it but I
can just about remember this and it was
really stupid because they'd always be a
mistake or you change your mind about
something which actually meant than what
you had to be written ended up being
written four times
older ogilvy people have told me that
you have to basically if you're a young
person at Ogilvy in the 1960s and 70s
you have to spend about two or three
hours a week as a kind of Terry Thomas
in the typing pool you have to do all
your go in Indian Belvin smoking jacket
and the reason for that is if you didn't
have a bank of favors and affection of
the typing pool you couldn't get
anything written and so you were more or
less ineffectual at your job you had to
everything you did was a favor trade
I've seen if people could just go I need
these seven things typed out but if you
were junior you'll put at the bottom of
the pile so your only chance of escaping
obscurity was by essentially doing the
Leslie Phillips Act it's bringing in the
dirt and it must be vented strong in a
sense and now the advantage of that of
course out over email was that the only
[ __ ] that got out was important because
you actually had to burn some favors to
get it produced whereas under email any
idiot to basically generate huge amounts
of work for somebody else without any
cost to themselves everyone who's
listening will know that right the
amount of tell you that email would be
an example of one of those so we're tech
goes wrong I think is really in question
because it's similar to where evolution
goes right inventiveness extraordinary
kind of extraordinary inventive
necessity and an unbelievable way to
solve problems laterally and through
unexpected sources but the downside is
that we we can essentially become
embroiled in utterly senseless
competition are the email I think email
is a case where it feels like work and
therefore we assume it's productive but
okay we're doing this as a video
conference okay now if this podcast were
recorded with us speaking at the speed
we can type with you know pauses of a
couple of hours in between responses so
my next sentence would be imagine if you
now
you wouldn't have
listeners in to be painfully slow but
when we're typing we're not conscious of
the contrast between the speed of typing
in the speed of speech so we think one
Titan quite fast here you know I'm
really being productive now despite the
fact that that email exchange that takes
place oh sorry we finished testing I
won't be long yeah okay so an email
exchange that takes place over three
days and takes an hour of your time
possibly could have been settled in a
four minute phone call yeah do you want
to do them now I wouldn't do that now
okay well okay you know but that but
weirdly when we're engaged in that three
day long hours hour and a half's time
crafting the e-mails back and forth
we're not conscious of the relative
inefficiency in the same way that we're
not conscious of the fact that the
Victoria lines much faster than other
tube lines and I don't know if you do
this but the central line of the
Victoria Line are pretty fast the
Jubilee lands fast nor the lines between
circle lines [ __ ] you know that's
continental drift basically but nobody
notices how fast the Victoria Line is
because the time between stations is
about the same what you don't realise
are the distance between stations is
much much further apart so actually
you're really well eing it on the
Victoria Line for significant periods of
time but our consciousness doesn't tell
us that
and I'd weirdly spent oh god any go
there I'd spent thirty years of getting
to Euston station not realizing that if
you go go to Victoria and get on the
Victoria Line you get to use at about
eight minutes I mean it's teleportation
compared to the other routes and so I
always find this really interesting I
mean a that where human perception lets
us down be where what we invest our time
and attention on in terms of innovation
can be extraordinarily counterproductive
and as I said I mean you know I would
say what we should have done is we
should have announced the alexa as you
know for all elderly people living alone
this is one of the best things to happen
in ten years
yeah and yet nobody's mentioned that
okay they all going
turn your lights on yeah you can do that
in a switch well the great story about
light switches and this is another
fascinating about how technology works
the first electric lights mimic the
first gas lights in the the switch was
beside the light you may remember the
American standard lamps often have that
thing you turn at the top and it seems a
bit weird to us but that's actually a
skeuomorphic mimic of how you turn a gas
light on and off by twisting a little
flange against a stick turn right and so
the first electric lights in America
you'd wander into the center of the room
reach up towards the bulb turn a knob
and the light would come off your
brilliance electric and then someone
simple you can actually put the switch
right next to the door so when you come
into the room you just turn the light on
now you'd think people go [ __ ] why
didn't we think of that okay but they
didn't they went one completely
unnecessary luxury so they wondered on
for 10 or 20 years basically bumping
into furniture in the dark trying to
find the light because this seemed them
at the time a completely unnecessary
indulgence it's this odd artifact of
what's already existed what's already
exist so I've already solved that
problem
so therefore in my mind it isn't a
problem because you know and it's really
fascinating you can actually find and I
was looking at this the other day I
looked on Google Images for ads for
electricity now you know if you ever
move to a house okay which wasn't on the
electrical grid right basically day one
you go okay the first thing we're going
to do is we've got to get this wine for
interesting yeah the idea that you'd
have a Salesman come out and explain to
you why it was a good idea
okay idea this guy would Africa around
again well the great advantage of having
electricity is you get what the [ __ ] you
talking exactly I mean just can you just
please put the wires but of course in
the early days you actually need you to
do this and it's fascinating because you
can see these ads and there's a
copyright of myself I can imagine myself
writing exactly the same [ __ ]
so sad I think about the Dublin
corporation encouraging people to get
electricity in their homes and one of
the great things it does it says will
Maureen with my new electric kettle okay
now you know I can simply flick it on I
don't need to light the stove and it
produces hot water now the copywriter
then goes on to imagine two possible
consumer benefits from this that none of
us have ever adopted he says so first of
all when I'm having tea with you I don't
leave the kettle on the stove I have it
on the table between us so if we need to
top up the pot I don't even need to get
up from the table okay yeah and every
night I take my kettle upstairs to bed
so I can have a cup of tea in the
bedroom okay now the fascinating there
is they make both of them a true to
benefit surrounding an electric kettle
is one you could make tea in any room in
the house okay - you can actually have
the kettle any way you want it to be not
necessarily on the stove the strange
thing is that nobody as far as they know
ever does any either of those two is a
stationary object it stays in the
station the object I've never moved in
anywhere else
the okay some people have a teas made
but it's never occurred to me you know
to take a kettle into my bedroom yep
thankfully put it in the cup downstairs
and the other thing as well as if if you
did do that okay yeah it's all done a
pin hole in your heart and then your
coal was leaking from the from the top
entry the tap and put the bullet pick so
on for paste only territory that's just
really useful things don't just a place
the whole lot own gives go pop
everything backside fantastic thanks
very much me that's great
thank you very much pleasure thanks if
you just slam the door yeah once you're
down that would be great
oh there we go
oh good you are your smoker perfect
thank you very much have a good day have
a good weekend it's all about
bye-bye are you wearing a SmartWatch
there Rory so here we are so first if
you look at electricity I mean one thing
that interests me about that is it
actually suggests that marketing and
consumer innovation are a significant
factor in determining economic growth we
never look at this we always assume that
supply creates its own demand that once
you invent electricity people just go or
[ __ ] Ellen where have you been all my
life but actually for the most part they
don't actually need to be persuaded I
mean there we know there were farmers in
Wales my father can remember who had
electricity to power their milking
machines in the cowshed but didn't want
it in the house
the so bizarre isn't it yes farmers - I
mean it's done yes it might not might
not be straight down the middle of the
representative demographic but yeah what
do you think this says about the value
of advertisers then because I know
you've got a very interesting in allergy
use about alchemy which I absolutely
love well I think that marketing and
advertising in terms of both behavior
change and also creating the context for
things that enables us to see why
they're desirable might be much much
more important in terms of economic
growth productivity and and just the
wealth of nations than economists have
given it credit for
now one thing I'd say is that the United
States enjoys a huge advantage as an
economy not only in its productive
capacity in scale it's you know size but
also in the nature and character of its
inhabitants which is for good a nail and
it's not always for good okay but
Americans are if we're being cynical and
European and a bit snooty they're a bit
credulous and some you know oh wow look
at this you know Greg Proops used to do
a fantastic comedy routine about this
which is you know the American at
Disneyland versus the Brit you know and
you see a giant 8-foot Mouse the
Americans getting AG kids do you see
that like he really does live here and
there was the British dad who sort of
looks rather there's a six-foot
maybe I got nothing better to be doing
so the American belief that life is
capable of continuous improvement which
I'm not have to say I mean most of the
nice things that have happened in
cynical Europe have probably happened on
the back of that American night you know
and you know just as actually most of
the really worthwhile [ __ ] was invented
by people in the sheds in the Midwest
you know let's give them credit for this
because I mean Brits haven't been bad
Scandinavians I mean you know and the
French do for French everywhere they're
either very conservative or very
inventive yeah I can't get my hands
around that at all they're like oh yeah
inventive creative people in the world
or like the most weirdly conservative
yeah and both I guess
but Tim but actually you know I mean you
know 50% of the innovations that
actually make life pleasant and livable
and easy you know probably come from the
US in some shape or form and they've
been adopted because of that American
belief that there's always a better way
of doing something is that because it's
such a young country do you think I
always I always think this one when I
think about the difference especially
between the UK and America I always draw
this analogy that the way that Americans
talk this kind of top-down love for the
country like I've never once heard an
English person say you know is I really
just love England I want to do it for my
country it's the sort of thing that you
associate with that far-right activists
and people with Skynyrd's shame actually
because we've got quite a lot to be
pretty I mean you know to me obviously
honest I mean the places living here
it's pretty great
actually yeah apart from January
February March yeah
there are I agree yeah I mean clear out
January if you can ever find a life my
father found enough said one of his
regrets was he said by the time you kids
had left home what I should have done in
my late 60s is bugger off to Spain for
January February March about you know
because it wouldn't have cost very much
turn the heating off at home you know
and you know those are the three worst
bits I remind you a hell of a lot of the
world has know that I mean Chicago is
beautiful in spring and
New York County New Yorkers are
convinced they have a great climate but
actually it's too [ __ ] cold in the
winter and it's too [ __ ] hot in the
summer when there's a heat wave in or a
cold snap in New York it's unlivable
where's London rarely does that you know
yeah and you know that I mean we're so I
mean there are places which have a
pretty perfect climate I guess in the
canary LA or Madeira la is pretty good
isn't it Chile apparently as a fantastic
climate but yeah there's this kind of
propensity towards accusing things of
being a [ __ ] which is so it's almost
like British people take pride in it to
a degree like that they're more
patriotic about the fact that they think
everything is [ __ ] than they are about
their own country
well I seriously worry about this
there's a weird one because if you look
at all these statistics which everybody
believes which is essentially all the
gains have gone to the richest X percent
okay and essentially the middle class
have become completely trapped in a kind
of income trap where they're earning no
more than their parents were now the
interesting thing about this narrative
is that according at least to Robert
Frank and sorry not Robin Frank Russ
Roberts sorry so she's not true now let
me just explain this is a second one
it's perfectly possible to have a
society where everybody is getting
richer but where every decile of the
population is getting poorer provided
people are moving from poorer deciles to
richard s l's now part of the reason
they're more poorer people is they're
more students or poor and there are more
there are more immigrants who tend to be
poorer when they start not necessarily
when they end and there are more retired
people then household composition is
smaller as well divorce has affected
things smaller you know smaller numbers
of people for household changes the
whole balance of things but actually if
you look at people if you look at what's
called panel data which is the same
people researched over time actually the
poorest the people who start off poorest
are very likely to become quite a bit
richer and the people who start off
richer over a period of 10 20 years are
quite likely to drop out of that top
decile really so the idea that there's
no social mobility if you look now
the only perspective that we care about
because I'm not an aggregate desam of
the population okay I don't you know and
the only thing we really care about is
my life getting better and for most
people it's set they're actually the
richest you tend to get a bit poorer for
most people who start off poor so
students for example are notionally poor
but they don't think of themselves as
poor in the same way that maybe retired
people don't because they've you know
they see themselves as investing in
their future to buy a product of that
particular area of their life that
particular period of their life right
yeah it's something you do in order to
become richer later on that's the logic
mind and whether that whether it's
overblown that's a separate totally
separate debate whether actually further
education has become a bit of a peacocks
tail you know kind of credential estar
ace I think he's probably true I'm doing
agree but I'll Park that for now because
it's a whole separate discussion I mean
I they know I think it's become a bit
crude I think you know that you now get
people who go well you know if I want to
get a really good job you know it's not
enough to have a degree I'm gonna have
an ending PhD in [ __ ] PhD I'm coming
out for [ __ ] sake you know I mean
actually you'll learn more in a job I
mean part of the thing that annoys me is
the implicit insult that when you're in
as an institution of higher education
you're learning loads and the second you
go into a job you become some sort of
slack-jawed mouth-breathing [ __ ] who
never learns anything I mean you know
you know I went to Cambridge for three
years I then spent three years at Ogilvy
working with people like Drayton Byrd
and Steve Harrison you know
extraordinary kind of creative people
and advertising people I've learned just
as much of those three years as Ogilvy
as I did in you know at university and
it's a it's it's a bit of a the idea
that somehow you need to be spending all
your time acquiring these credentials
strikes me as a you know pretty dubious
a degree I couldn't I couldn't agree
more when when I went to university I
started I sat next to my business
partner in my first ever seminar sat
down sat down next to him complained
about the fact that I was skinned and
from then we started working together in
12 years later I've still not being able
to get rid of him but you'll be
listening I'll receive a pay cup for
that
because he's one that controls the
accounts as well and so what you do by
the way is I've just read about this but
this group detained in Dubai you moved
to Dubai and then you get him to sign
checks right and then you cancel the
check so he gets sent to jail fantastic
which yet then you refuse to honor as
the partner and then he gets banged up
in jail and you take over the companies
apparently it works every time I'll have
to make sure that he doesn't listen to
this one so he's not expecting it but
that'll be fine
so yeah we sat down we sat down next to
each other in our first ever seminar and
very quickly we started operating a
business from HR advertising marketing
dealing with suppliers dealing with
consumers everything front and
backward-facing is vertically and
horizontally integrated as you can
imagine and at the same time I was doing
a business degree at Newcastle and I was
dealt a fatal dose of contrast between
what the real world was showing me and
what my academics was showing me and
very quickly I became so disenchanted
disenfranchised with what I was learning
I think had I've been doing philosophy
or psychology or something it might have
fed my passion a little bit more but as
I was sat learning about Henry Ford's
scientific methods of like operations
and Kaizen logistics and stuff like that
I just thought like what am i doing like
this does not reflect the business world
that I am being exposed to and then sure
enough iiiii came out and I thought well
it the piece of paper for me I'm the
absolute avatar for got a piece of paper
that I didn't need spent and I suspect
this was before the 9000 pounds a year
thing I was like three grand a year and
I've still come out with like 27 grand
27 grand of debt for a degree that
essentially facilitated me running a
business if you offered people that 27
thousand pound own and said you can
spend 1/3 of it you have to spend 1/3 of
in our education but the other 18 grand
you can spend on anything you like
starting a business moving house getting
you know whatever okay everybody would
do one year degree wouldn't they well
maybe to us nobody would do 3 you'd want
9 on 9 or 18 grand
the other [ __ ] 18-grand of 2006 was a
deposit on a house that was a de part of
your embassy right yeah they said so
that's not a market in education saying
here's money which will lend for you
just as the housing market is in the
market because the mortgage is money
they'll lent you on the sole condition
that you spend it on property so
unsurprisingly houses are really [ __ ]
expensive student loan is 27 grand
they'll lend you on the sole proviso
that you spend it all on education now
you know I mean to ever see honest I
will spend two years of Cambridge and
bought a [ __ ] Mustang or something
but I mean actually I mean I mean this
is one of those interesting questions
which is I would argue that it's one of
the interesting ideas but you know may
interest people on the right and left
and as a result makes no progress
because nobody gets angry about it but
actually giving people money in lumps
and there's a whole load of experiments
in the effective altruism movement but
the problem with welfare is partly and
you know it's partly right-wing people
are too reluctant to give it which is
one interesting question but left-wing
people tend to have this view that if
you give people a large sum of money
they'll immediately get pissed now
what's interesting in all the
experiments where you give people not
regular small and if you give me a
hundred quid a month
what really improves my life when I've
got a hundred quid a month that's how I
got 40 pounds of discretionary income a
month what improves my life's most
answer beer and cigarettes right because
if I only got 40 pounds a month of
discretionary income the best way of
improving my life is to get pissed with
my friends and to have a tap on the
highest immediate return yeah immediate
return it's fantastic now you give
people 3 grand they start asking
different questions you know 5 minutes
should I move how do I really need to
buy a car do I really need to get
educated and if you look at these
experiments in Africa where you go
around and they they find genuinely
deserving people typically if you've got
a house which is entirely made of
natural materials if it doesn't mean
you're a hipster in Africa it means
you're genuinely poor okay if you have
not any concrete you haven't got
corrugated iron you're really poor so
they identify those people and basically
send them through their mobile phone
like the year's salary both about that
and the number of women actually spend
it on booze and cigarettes is
unbelievably tiny but what's fascinating
is they don't spend it in the way the
charity assumes is important they all
spend it on totaling of things educating
their kids might be the priority
actually getting a proper roof on the
house might be the priority one person
actually did by recording equipment
which looked a bit of an indulgence but
he then started a band and made quite a
lot of money out of it and so there's a
real there's some really interesting
questions about welfare which is the
right tend to disapprove them it's the
left tend to do it in a really
patronizing way and actually if you say
look to and to some extent right when
people in favor of this it's they go one
of the bastards gonna get pissed no
[ __ ] the right-wing people maybe a
bit actually although for the worst of
reasons they may actually be right here
but you're saying you know actually if
everybody at the beginning of their life
I hadn't inheritance from an arm's of a
thousand quid when I was bloody I was
20-something okay that sounds a bit
ridiculous that it was at the time it
was life-changing knowing you had a
thousand quid in the bank which if you
needed it you could spend it and then
later on another aunt died and I had
about twenty okay
and that basically enabled me to get a
deposit or a flaccid able be to furnish
the flat name we didn't do done now you
know huge amount of my present property
wealth is probably predicated on that
twenty thousand quid which mainly get
started a bit earlier so I'm starting to
wonder should the student loan be
available for anything do you say okay
you've got to spend one year of hidden
further education if you spent eighteen
thousand pounds and you want to start a
cafe or you want to start a business and
by the way one thing about small
businesses I think we all we all have
mentioned more is that okay there are
areas where the business needs to be big
I don't want my broadband to be provided
by a bloke down the pub okay I get that
but small business activity adds an
enormous amount to the well-being of
communities why do you think you know
every time a shop opens a
they opens you know you know it more or
less defines what's a successful
thriving community actually one of the
things you and Newcastle now are you in
Manchester Newcastle still now
interestingly what I find interesting
when you travel to other British cities
is there are thee that cities that did
really well in the kind of early part of
the century a new council is probably
one of them isn't it actually I mean you
go to their ship fields another one you
come out of the station I went to
Sheffield in 1987 and we missed the last
train and we said to our host where's
the best place to stay without Sheffield
you replied Leeds the fact that people
open you know whether it's hotels
plumbing firms cafes all that sort of
activity actually has an importance in
human day-to-day human life which we
can't really you know we shouldn't
really understate and so I would argue
that you should change the student loan
and just say it's a young person's loan
everybody gets it spend it Irish and you
spend as you wish with the provider that
may be I think a year should we spend on
education yeah then you know if you want
to go and do three years and do that
stuff well okay but you should pay the
cost that that's 18,000 you can't spend
on something else yeah I totally get
that um I wanted to talk about the
recent UK advertising watchdog release
that smoked about how it will be
cracking down on what it termed sexist
stereotypes in ads do you think this is
a significant change or is it natural
progression what's what's your view on
this but something's that the sexist
stereotype in a sense there's been a
reverse sexist stereotype for quite a
long time which is which a lot of men
find very irritating which is you have
to portray the man as a bit of an idiot
and the woman is the sage font of all
wisdom Oracle because if you do it the
other way around you get massive
complaints I think that can get a bit
you know that can get a bit tedious
there is a problem of course with
stereotyping in advertising in TV which
is simply that
oh okay oh if you only have 30 seconds
there is an element where when you've
got 30 seconds or 60 seconds to tell a
story to some extent you have to rely on
tropes because things which are odd okay
throw the viewer completely you need the
archetype right to be able to in a first
so little more of the contents Laurie by
the way by the way changing ethnic
stereotypes Italian favor of that I mean
it's worth remembering that you get you
get some weird stuff going on in that
there was that much applauded Nike ad
about London which is very very
ethnically diverse except for a complete
absence of Indians anybody of
sub-continental origin seems to be
completely missing
now maybe cuz people have people in the
sub comes it only really interested in
one sport which is cricket yeah quite an
icon now you can crickets oh yeah yeah
and so so there may be an element of
that but um we I mean I don't know I
mean good advertising first of all you
could you can you can push it
stereotypes but you can only push so
fast and so far because you know if you
think about it if you'd shown for
example it would have been very good in
1970 to show a gay couple in one sense
as an archetype or you know creating in
a norm but the ad would have become
entirely about all discussion of the ad
would have become entirely about that so
he didn't you had the Apso family
because then you just said default
family this is what family is alike okay
and then the centrality of oXXO was
communicated in the way that would have
been much more difficult if you'd set
out to be an absolute I mean okay you
could have made Goodfellas not using for
example Italian Americans or Sicilians
yeah okay but using other Latvians right
and it would have been less hysteria
time but it also would have been a bit
of a weird film you would but you
wouldn't have got you wouldn't have
communicated across the subtlety I talk
about this a lot when
people mention love island to me they
talk about the TV show and they say that
there's a lack of diversity in terms of
character depth and complexity in that
and I'm like look you've got 45 minutes
of 14 people's 24-hour periods like it's
like 350 hours of lived life every day
that you need to try to fit in yeah any
like you do not have the time to convey
the subtlety and the nuance of someone's
very specific views about exactly what
they want from a girl or a guy it needs
to be that's the hero that's the villain
that's the maid and that's the redeemed
that's the nerd that's the data because
it allows us to expedite the route from
character introduction to character
maturity no I think you're absent in
terms of short storytelling under
constraints there's a there's this first
of all you want attention to be attached
to something where you know in one place
and so anything to weird David Ogilvy
always said look if you just want your
ads to gain attention to show a gorilla
and a jockstrap the point is you can
gain attention right but the danger is
if you do anything to now Ford got into
huge trouble because when they
reproduced an ad showing factory workers
in Essex in Poland right they replaced
some of the black faces with white faces
for the Polish market now I I didn't go
on TV to defend this because the whole
thing had become a kind of PR nightmare
but you gotta remember that the
population of Poland is probably onion
in 99.5% white that if there's a car
factory in Poland the car workers are
overwhelmingly Polish ancestry now if
you had had a car factory with the
correct ethnic mix which was perfect
used in the British brochure by the way
I'm not now you could say okay this is
because poles are racist which is not an
implausible hypothesis okay
but equally to have let's say 30%
Caribbean employees in what is supposed
to be a Polish car factory would be like
having a British car factory where there
were seven Navajo Indians the point is
that you wouldn't you be gain what the
[ __ ] representative right it's simply
not representative and they got in a
huge grief about that and I'm you know
it was an insensitive thing to have done
but at the same time I understand why
they did it because simply you know if
you're in Poland the ethnic composition
of Poland Hungary Czech Republic or
whatever is not the ethnic composition
of London are you going on amend your
approach as you move forward at Ogilvy
are you is this something that you're
genuinely concerned about or is it
something you've been ahead of the curve
on already
it'll be as majors he was definitely
ahead of the curve in terms of female
employment and female promotions so I
occasionally get a bit baffled by the
kind of discussions the ad industry has
beating up because every single division
of Ogilvy I've worked with and four has
probably in the last 20 years if you
split it up it's been run equally by men
and women the ad agency has had female
management for a significant time the
design component the direct marketing
components all of them have had
significant female management input it's
also worth remembering that to some
extent the composition of an ad agency's
board depends on the gender balance of
who had agencies recruited in 1988 yeah
there's another ceiling so looking my
contention is that the advertising
industry and the communications industry
will be majority female at all levels
and in most departments not necessarily
the creative department but that will
grow closer and closer to 5050 in about
20 years current management planning
most of these disciplines will become
majority female in a certain length of
time creative departments slightly odd
because what some creatives have said to
me is if you recruited from art colleges
it tended to be guys who went to the
advertising course and women went to
fine art design or fashion so you might
have had a fashion
apartment of the art college which was
disproportionately female and you might
have had a department which was just
disproportionately male and it's not
entirely fair to say that's prejudice
rather than preference having said that
I don't think creative departments will
be overwhelmingly male normal creative
directors be overwhelmingly male in the
other 20 years what I do believe is
conservative is there's a natural a
small C conservative is there is a
natural pace of change and one thing
that sometimes annoys me about these
movements is that I support the aim of
the movement I think the movement is
completely right and I want to see I
share its aspirations but if I ever step
in and say no you're you know I'm
telling me what you're trying to do but
the way you're trying to do it is wrong
or the way you're diagnosing the problem
is wrong the assumption is not this guy
is trying to help by suggesting there
may be other explanations instead you're
treated as basically one of the enemy
it's implication is that you're trying
to deny not trying your trust in value
now to some extent you know when I was
recruited by Ogilvy we were about 12 of
us maybe 14 graduate trainees and I
think the ratio was something like
two-to-one male female don't know why
that was it's worth remembering by the
way that HR which is responsible for
recruiting is it most company is a bit
of a matriarchy so you could raise a
little bit of a question which is long
HR has been a fairly well gender
balanced if anything or female dominated
female dominated discipline for quite a
long time
what were you [ __ ] doing for the
first you know 10 years of this yeah is
it if you get women are oppressing women
here or not impossible I mean if you
look at it it's very Darwinian point of
view of course this was a slight bias
for some uncertain men to recruit women
okay now which is also looked down upon
that's also not a historically you had
advantages in certain forms of
employment but I mean I mean by the way
that women bias against women is not an
impossible
the point to make is that there are
multiple variations here there's okay
the senior people are product of who was
hired in 1988 it's also a product of
maternity leave I accept the fact that
actually my career wouldn't have I
wouldn't be vice chairman of Ogilvy if I
had been at home looking after kids
between I don't know 1999 and 2008 okay
right if I don't have looked after kids
effectively I would have had to reboot
my career I totally accept that my way
as a partial explanation what I did what
I did my not keen on is just this thing
which is anywhere where it's not 50/50
there is therefore evidence of prejudice
that's too simplistic not saying that
prejudice doesn't exist of course it
exists and that exists in both
directions and from both genders by the
way that patently there is prejudice but
this is the big but it's not fair to say
there is prejudice there is inequality
or imbalance ergo the only source of the
of the imbalance is the prejudice
because there are loads of one of them
is preference okay simply speaking if
you look at countries very liberal
countries like Sweden or Norway you will
find that accountancy and perhaps being
an actuary is disproportionately male
and Nursing is disproportionately female
but you can't scare a lot of the jobs
that females tend towards in these more
egalitarian countries like Sweden and
such like they scale more difficult more
poorly than STEM fields that if you're a
nurse how many patients can you look
after at once like maybe 10 20 I guess I
don't know but if you are someone who's
create there you go you've got 7 billion
people at your behest
so yeah I totally agree I'm running but
by the way none of these none of these
findings has any bearing on the
judgement of an individual because what
often isn't understood in this debate is
the difference between aggregate and
individual so you know where you get
considerable overlap ok
the what you will see is at the very
extreme tails the time
person who wants to become an actuary
okay is well I mean okay it no I mean
they're gonna be slightly teensy bit on
the spectrum maybe which is by the way
trends mail as well yep
you know it's a very extreme take now is
it that I'm nobody's saying for a second
that there can't be female actuaries I'm
simply saying that if you expect
actuaries and scaffolders and nurses to
be 50/50 male/female you're gonna have a
long wait yeah unless you impose social
engineering of a level that most of us
wouldn't find acceptable yeah and that's
gonna lead to more dissatisfaction
longer term right as well I mean there's
an interesting theory by the way which
is born at my own anecdotal experience
which is the main reason women there are
two problems with stem and getting women
well they're loads of problems about
women in stem one of them is if you do
stem you're more or less encouraged free
levels to do maths physics chemistry
what that means is you haven't got room
to do a nice humanity subject now I
think someone's got to change I did
maths Latin and Greek which was I'm
really glad I did that in now as an
adult it was a total pain in the ass at
a time because I'm only doing maths and
physics effectively it was the same [ __ ]
with different diagrams right whereas I
had to go from you know reading Homer to
then you don't I don't know yeah I know
students T distribution or whatever it
was okay my memories hazy on that one
and it was a bit of a mindfuck so
there's that problem which is an or more
women than men are going to be reluctant
to say those subjects are really enjoyed
in them Jim one of the theories is that
by the way what tends to happen is that
they're the reason more men go into stem
is simply that there are more men who
has [ __ ] at history English languages
now modern languages was always a female
dominated field at university and if you
noticed that but it tended to be the
modern languages faculty was the Playboy
Mansion
yeah of the the Cambridge that was the
thinking man's that was the thinking
man's degree yeah
and so what tips are happen is that if
you're if you
all the men who do stand ten not only to
be men who are good at stem they tend to
be men who are not very good at history
English geography French there are fewer
women who are [ __ ] at history English
geography French therefore fewer women
do stem because men who are good at both
tend to do art subjects as well yep
because it's less calm less competitive
more fun so interesting me my brother
okay okay in history English and stuff
didn't like it that much
he's an astrophysicist he went to do a
totally stem career his contemporary who
was equally good at both in other words
he acted in the theater and you know he
was you know really keen actor he
actually went off did history even
though he was equally good really at
maths ya know maybe not quite as good as
my brother but he was very good at maths
he was very good at history he did
history my brother was very good at
maths he was quite good at history he
did math yeah now what you'll tend to
find is that if women are more naturally
strong in humanities fields and
therefore there's less need for them to
find a subject of study where their
weakness doesn't apply yeah and stem is
a fantastic escape for someone who's
basically as I hate writing essays but I
love solving quadratic wage that's me
all over yeah yeah yeah so I wanted to I
wanted to ask what your thoughts are in
the future of the attention economy and
whether or not people are going to
continue to give away their attention in
their data so readily
it's very interesting on data I'm
completely messed up because it's my
attitude to data it's a bit like they
asked you to I have towards weather
might should what my children do on the
internet and that was always the problem
which is look I can either police them
to within an inch of their lives or I
can just trust them there doesn't seem
to be a very easy middle ground that
doesn't involve a huge amount of work
just in to me so I either I basically go
and say to my kids look you know if you
see anything in the Internet that
disturbs you or if there's a bloke being
a bit pervy and weird let me know and
I'm gonna trust you otherwise go and
look at what you like which is what I
more or less did all you do this thing
which I often think backfires by the way
which is you police every minute of
their use you put you know every single
safeguard on their bloody internet
access which simply means they go around
to their friend's house and look at porn
harbors for like it's me it tends I know
that those people whose parents and the
children I know tissues parents and most
protective are also the most devious
yeah yeah it just drives it underground
this is drivers drivers you see it was a
recent New York Times article saying
that silk and Silicon Valley tech
workers make sure that their children's
nannies keep them away from all
technology and that some of these
nannies get sucked if they come home and
find that their child says I played on
an iPad today or I did this that and the
other which says an awful lot like the
same as Steve Jobs Steve Jobs wouldn't
let his kids have iPads oh yeah I think
it's the same it's the same theory as
drug dealers don't use their own supply
right which I think super interested you
think about the attention economy then
as we move forward how's that gonna work
so the data question I think is
sometimes overblown actually in the the
idea that this is the new oil the data
question is assumed to be absolutely
vital when it's actually sometimes
useful sometimes useless I think that a
large number of people in tech and
indeed a large number of people in
advertising
marketing have misunderstood out that
how marketing works and they've tried to
turn it into an efficiency game and I
think a large reason why marketing works
is precisely because it's inefficient
the costly signaling in other words the
fact that you're talking to a large
group of people simultaneously through
media which you perceive to be expensive
using celebrities or creative talent or
filmmaking skills or storytelling skills
which are in short supply and therefore
seen as scarce and valuable is what
actually gives advertising its meaning
now how do you send a wedding invitation
now you could send it by email but that
we really [ __ ] wouldn't it naturally no
one would come because they'd assumed
there was gonna be a pay a cash bar you
know okay in order to send a wedding
invitation that says I'm committed to
this partnership
you can throw money at it you know which
is you know full-page ad in vogue okay
it's gilt-edged wedding invitation
printed on hard card with engraved curly
type after one and my I've got one of my
fridge which is the fridge magnet that's
got a heart and it's made on woods and
it seemed really now you throw a stack
of money on that and you do it
conventionally and everybody goes wow
this is a serious wedding well you know
one's not turning up to that wedding
either you could use craft an effort
which you could make something by hand
you could use humor which is another
scarce commodity you could produce an
email newsletter that was really really
funny but what you couldn't do is just
email the parents of florinda so-and-so
request the pleasure of your company at
the measure of their marriage their
daughter or so-and-so to mr. Dave
whatever it is okay
you can't send that as an email the
meaning actually resides not in the
textual informational component this
isn't really information theory this is
signaling theory and they're different
things and the obsession with data is
all about how can we make this message
really efficient but in a way there can
be really clever efficient messages and
I don't dispute that that's part of
whatever
is about but the real way you build
trust in a brand is to make it is to
make it famous in an expensive way yeah
do you think that this is people doing
the avoiding doing a hard thing which is
the very very creative copywriting which
is the subtle and nuanced approach to
delivering a message to the market and
stuff like that and focusing instead on
this slightly more kind of spectrum side
use of the data where it's what
frequency what open rate what particular
kind of etc etc I think Silicon Valley
sees everything as an efficiency game it
sees everything as a time and money
optimization problem and it's now
straying into fields where that doesn't
apply don't get me wrong in things like
manufacturing and you know in in in in
certain areas the correlation beam
efficiency and effectiveness is pretty
high you know economists aren't totally
insane about this but in various things
marketing military strategy would be
another one you know there quite a few
areas of life where actually the
asymmetry between the sender and the
receiver or the attacker of the defender
the informational asymmetry requires you
to do things which are irrational and
the very thing there was a case where a
man basically tried to murder his wife
by tampering with her parachute and if
you saw this no he was next military guy
and weirdly he nearly got away with it
because she wouldn't testify against him
and they thought what the hell he wasn't
allowed to approach her he was obviously
under a kind of order how on earth did
he get to her and persuade her not to
testify and they found that he'd written
songs love songs patently addressed to
her and placed them on YouTube and Sam I
got had watched them right now one that
strikes me as fascinating okay is if
he'd simply emailed her and said I'm
innocent I'm innocent I'm innocent it
wouldn't have worked yeah okay well if
you tried to use reason if you let's say
you had no money but you have a lot of
musical talent you wanted to send out a
great wedding invitation you could
record a fantastic song about your
wedding or your love for your future
bride
and you can post it on YouTube and you
could email the guests and invitation to
watch it okay obviously you'd have to
bake in a kind of a private YouTube
channel otherwise you get thousands of
gatecrashers yeah but that would be that
would be equivalent because it's costly
in terms of money cost in terms of
effort in terms of talent you know
poetry is in a sense more costly prose
yeah poetry means more than prose
because it's harder to write and in the
same way there's an effort to make
everything efficient is a bit like
trying to take you know Keats and
rewrite it in prose yeah but I I think
it's a it's a fundamental mistake and of
course data if you believe this to be
true data becomes absolutely everything
because you know all the human talents
of persuasion and seduction ah external
to your models so all you have to do is
get the right information to the right
person at the right time and that's
purely a data game now of course that
suits Google and Facebook and everyone
else to pretend it's a date again
because that's where they have a
monopoly they have an awfully on that
kind of data and they can't claim
monopoly on creative talent they can't
cram a monopoly over celebrity they
can't claim a monopoly over persuasive
about ability or psychology but they can
claim a monopoly over what they know so
they pretend advertising is the kind of
game in which they aren't they're
unavoidable now you can't blame them for
doing it we all do the same kind of
thing we all pretend that the areas
where we're strong are more important
than they really are yeah you know and
so but but at the same time um the the
data question is unbelievably flamin
complicated because we've been naive in
the West because we've always had
relatively nice governments you know who
what's happening in China with the
business where everybody has a kind of
citizens eBay rating yes this is being
developed in China now it may be a
terrible mistake
because suddenly everybody below a3 is
identified as a group and they may rebel
or revolt you're just increasing tribal
you're creating zeal a zone for the
people who are sub 3 r18 aren't you it's
like there's an actual episode of Black
Mirror that which is which is about this
and then it's somehow it's occurring in
real life and no one's actually taking
well now I'm sorry that you need to
think about who you talk to who your
friends are who your friends are on
social media who your parents were all
those things affect your rating and your
rating effects whether you can travel
whether you can travel overseas whether
you do this whether you can do that and
of course eBay if eBay gives me a [ __ ]
right here I can just create a new
identity or move onto Etsy or something
but with the government
that's everything where you can live
where you can move how freely you can
travel where you can work whether you
get a job or not it's all affected by a
kind of credit rating on steroids now
that's a terrifying terrifying thing I
mean particularly when you automate it
so there's no I'm not even comfortable
there's the great thing about there's
data which is information and there's
data which does things I'm not very
comfortable with the speed camera I
don't think we should have accepted it
because I think in order to be find it
is not enough to say I drove at 40 in a
30 limit therefore I should have three
points and 100-pound fine I think a
human should watch the footage and the
human should have discretion over
whether or not an find where were you
overtaking someone where you start again
with ID an animal where you do in one
case I'd be wrong
I've had about four of these in my
lifetime and three of them were totally
deserved and I die the speed awareness
course so I took the points one of them
were where was where there was a driver
who was either drunk or having a massive
ride with his wife who's swerving all
over the road so I just waited for them
to move into the left-hand Lane of a
dual carriageway and basically well heed
it for 300 yards yeah as the only safe
way of getting past yeah now any cop
would have arrested them not me anybody
watching the film footage in the wider
context would have said I can see why
this guy did that general human should
have had a dashcam
you know I never thought aloud they
weren't really available then I guess no
this was um this about eight to ten
years ago so it is you could have got
them but that is a fair point actually
which is you could actually say look
this is these are the circumstances I
want you to take this into consideration
I wonder whether or not they consider
that I recently got my first three
points I didn't know that a
long-wheelbase van one up from a transit
van is classed as a commercial vehicle
and means that it's got a national speed
limit on a single carriageway 50 miles
an hour not six I didn't know that well
there you go if at some point in the
future you're driving so I didn't know
so I remember I was going to go and pick
up a couch with my dad my dad's in the
car I'm driving along and the van didn't
have one of these classic enterprise
things like the most basic of equipment
that you can no air conditioning and no
cruise control etc as I'm driving to
Leeds for Newcastle and I'm on this
single carriageway and I remember seeing
the mobile speed unit on the left and
look down and I was like sixty one
single carriageway piece of piss
absolutely fine I'll be I'll be laughing
well I didn't realize was that I was 11
miles an hour over over the 50 the 50
limit for the vehicle I'm like well like
I got this thing through and I've got
you've got to send off your lights I
didn't even know how to send my license
off it it didn't come back with a hole
in it I don't know why they need my
license to like everything's done
electronically anyway but yeah and that
would that was a bizarre one I think
well there's more subtlety in new ones
to that particular situation like yeah
maybe before I drove the van should I
have what looked at whether or not there
was a different national speed limit
yeah but it's not that like I don't know
I knew that no clue and then the other
interesting one is it's not quite
acceptable to impose a speed limit on
dual carriageways or multi-lane
motorways because the very strong rule
there is you've got to go a bit faster
than the cars to your left
yeah because if all the cars are
traveling at the same speed of a high
density of traffic it's impossible to
change lane and people can't actually
get off the motorway yeah so you have to
have some degree of flow to prevent the
whole thing becoming kind of gridlocked
yeah and
you know you have to accept that if the
people at the left turn lane again 50 of
the people in the lane to the right are
going to be going 54 and the people that
are the fast lane are going to be going
58 because that's just how we drive it's
an instinctive thing you Americans
aren't like that they have different way
of driving they'll sit they'll sit on an
interstate side by side for half an hour
yeah you know the same speed and then
they'll also weave weave in and out of
each other as we know we've been out
there undertake a bit yeah but also of
course it was memory in America and
partly American West it's 15 miles
between intersections you know it's a
totally different it's a totally
different mode of driving anyway yeah
and so no that's an interesting I mean
that's an interesting question which is
you know the the so in the Chinese case
there's the question of context you know
you could end up being marked down for
talking to these suspicious foreign
spies when all they were doing is asking
directions to some tourist site I want a
coffee where's good for a coffee around
here yeah exactly yeah and so the
ability to actually get yourself out by
saying okay explain air idly explain
this suddenly becomes totally impossible
and you in a way a really bad
bureaucracy and automation will
naturally lead to bureaucracy is worse
than a tyranny in a way yeah yeah
because it's automated
it's totally automated and your ability
to actually get everything expunged is
more or less impossible yeah well even
in a tyranny at least the tyranny hybrid
love you yeah the tyrannical notion is
it's deployed by a human there's an
element at least a small element of
margin on either side yes yeah so final
question that I wanted to ask was your
vision of advertising moving forward
I've got George who is one of the guys
that works on their modern wisdom
project asked why what you think the ROI
and advertising will look like as we
move forward the skills required won't
go away
and I don't think they're nearly as
different as the digital people are
trying to pretend they're that they're
among young people and digital people
have a vested interest in pretending
that everything's changed and everything
old is dead because it effectively means
they can occupy the
top jobs because the experience of
people older than them has suddenly
become worthless and there's a no-no I
can't blame young people for going with
that gig in a way because I mean you
know it's a it's a very good story to
tell it's kind of plausible however I
think that there are some really
interesting questions to be asked about
advertising which is how do you do
costly signaling in a digital medium
which is a really insane question in
other words we've got the digital
equivalent of Yellow Pages we've done
that very well and Google is to some
extent you know Google Plus Amazon
whatever is you know we've done digital
Yellow Pages Facebook is arguably you
know the digital sort of AT&T you know
but we haven't got the digital
equivalent really of the back page of
Vogue now maybe maybe there are things
like you know you actually create an
epic series you know with you know you
know what's the digital clones are
sponsoring the Olympics taking the back
page of Vogue now for small businesses
by the way I ought to make important
caveat here there's a difference when
consumers asked how costly your wedding
invitation is right they're also sub
constantly factoring in how rich they
think you are or know you are now if
you're worth okay 10 million quid you
send the invitation out on photo copier
paper that's much much weirder than if
you're getting married as a student and
you send the invitation out on photo
copier paper now it's worth remembering
that my local I just went to the opening
of the deal pier kitchen which is the
new cafe at the end of deal pier and
it's to young people in their 20s have
opened it and they post on Facebook and
they post their menu and they ask for
suggestions for what other breakfast
dishes might be attractive tin jury I
think we go but anyway ah and um but are
doing that the better money you don't
have to do it it involves a certain
amount of effort I get it you're busy
running a restaurant the fact that a pub
or a cafe or restaurant post on Facebook
regularly and is keen to promote itself
on social
or Instagram or whatever is to some
extent a form of effortful costly
signaling that isn't really true if
you're Nestle or coca-cola okay because
the difference is if a student biases in
his film say a 500 kid engagement ring
its costly signaling if Rupert Murdoch
does it isn't yep and so we've got to
remember that the cost is also
proportionate to the perceived costs in
terms of discretionary effort what you
might call discretionary effort or
expense and you know as I said I think
Facebook is a very very good local
advertising vehicle I follow every
single pub Cafe you know whatever and
I'm impressed by the ones you make an
effort to do this really well but that
isn't the same if you're you know
Giorgio Armani or if you're Nestle or if
you're coca-cola you need a different
canvas in order to display discretionary
cost I get that
I think what's particularly interesting
for me looking at the internet marketing
world and what I get exposed to a lot of
the time is that the this moving
slightly back to the discussion about
data there's this obsession with getting
the data right as opposed to necessarily
making the message resonate with the
audience
yeah it's that the very specific kind of
russell brunson click funnel if you use
this kind of copy with a countdown timer
then you've retargeted them with an
upsell in three days via email then if
they don't click through on that then
you follow this particular thing down to
me that the art and the subtlety and the
actual connection that is made between
consumer and brand that is being
replaced with an algorithmic logic
puzzle and at the end of that there is
particular formula forget about the
message don't bother yourself with the
creative and then what you get out of
the other side of that is successful
business now I'm Stingley I
unfortunately haven't got it because
I've got British gas at smart metering I
haven't got it on my current app but
there are ways in which I
think a really impressive thing you can
do is just show you understand consumer
psychology very well so there's the
effort which is which often is partly
data-driven but isn't this I mean one of
things I loved is the British Gas app
has a little thing where you submit a
meter reading now most gas meters in the
UK I kind of under the stairs or there
in a weird cupboard or a shed or some
other weird thing and the person who
designed that app all credit to them
just added a little switch which turn
the tour actually on I've got my er
month yeah under the same thing okay now
that sort of thing is just really smart
and lovely because it shows we didn't
have to do this no one would ever go
[ __ ] thing didn't even had a talk
[ __ ] right no one in research would have
said it would help if you had a torch
but someone thought now that's an
example of discretionary effort or
discretionary you know that someone made
the budget available and had that and
bothered to put enough attention into
this to think actually there gonna be
loads of cobwebs it's gonna be dark and
musty and they can't see and we're back
to designing for the disabled again I
suppose in a funny kind of way yeah but
it's just that there is this weird thing
which is the other thing I think that I
noticed as a criticism of digital is
there's not enough attention to given to
what happens when things go wrong so
they optimize a fantasy version of the
customer journey and they don't think of
what happens when that journey doesn't
happen to plan hmm
so I hate criticizing jaundice because
generally I love them I get the stuff to
live into my local Waitrose and his fat
it's fabulous and you know they've led
they do wonderful advertising it's a
great brand it's a partnership I love it
but I wanted a Dyson from Jonas and it
was supposed to be delivered the next
day at Waitrose and I never got a text
saying it turned up but after about two
days it said it'll be dispatched and
arrive tomorrow so I assumed it must
mean that time when they said no it
seems to well one of the driving for me
but the Dyson despair okay now they must
have known that it
or they must have the data to know that
it hadn't arrived okay so a bit of me I
rang them up and I said why do I have do
they said what you have to do is reorder
will refund you and you you reorder will
send you another one I said why is this
my problem okay because you should have
noticed that it didn't arrive you
should've texted me to say there's Peter
delay
you should have canceled that first all
or sent out the second one and said
don't worry it'll be there tomorrow I
wouldn't even noticed because I won't
you know I'm that desperate to have the
thing go go you know right Luke and
instead I'm suddenly the second this is
where bureaucracies I think is so
telling the second something goes wrong
you find yourself in a spiraling
nightmare of calf gas you know total
chaos
yeah where there's nothing you can
bloody do about it yeah I did feel about
that bahama there should be a [ __ ]
algorithm that says has it arrived if no
forward to person yeah decide what to do
and it humanizes that the company side
right if they'd said if they run me up
and said look we [ __ ] up a bit yeah um
sorry about this but doesn't meet with
you tomorrow
I was up what a great company yeah you
know because you've actually taken an
initiative and you're actually looking
out for me and said I I mean I I'm
worried about all this stuff because I
think there's this optimization thing
which is all based around a kind of
fantasy of how the world is supposed to
work and in so many ways a the world
doesn't work like that because [ __ ]
happens and things go wrong and I wonder
that when tech people of designing
they're looking for this naive Nirvana
situation which you can demonstrate in
which when it works to plan looks really
cool but in many cases they may be
optimizing completely the wrong thing so
they may be obsessed with getting the
thing there in one day rather than two
whereas what I really want is just you
know is actually really regular tracking
to tell these wanna know where they're
yeah yeah yeah you know that may be what
they're trying to do is actually
optimizing what seems to be the what
might be the sort of operations element
of optimization not the psychological
element of optimization
then you get back to all my [ __ ] about
Trane saying the point that actually
making trains faster is relatively of
secondary importance for many train
journeys in the UK because you can now
work on the Train actually the most
important train technology in the last
20 years is Wi-Fi plus a table because
if you've got Wi-Fi on a table I mean
mister genuinely if you ever invite me
to speak in Newcastle I would say to my
PA
the Newcastle Liverpool Manchester
basically say yes Cheers well it's not
to aerial conference what the hell you
going there for we know you know and I
go yeah but I get four hours on the
train which is the most productive I'm
gonna be all week yeah you're insulated
in this hermetically sealed environment
no one's bothering you you've got no
idea they might bring me a bit of tea
and coffee and laughing and so what's so
interesting is that to some extent
every time you attach these kind of
rationale metrics to what you're trying
to do you pay a very large crater of
opportunity cost because maybe the thing
you'll really need to optimize isn't
actually numerically expressible it's
not it's not a metric it's a feeling how
do you scale that then I think what you
do need is you do need just behavioral
science to go in and say we have quite a
lot of evidence to show that all a
people don't know what they want they
don't they can't say what they want but
we have quite a lot of evidence about
people's emotional state that they care
actually much more than they think about
X and much less than they think about Y
and therefore if you optimize either
what consumers say they want or what
economic logic seems to dictate you
might be missing where the real where
the real money shot is in this activity
I totally get it
Rory today's been absolutely fantastic
I'm right in saying that within the next
couple of months you're gonna have a
book coming out is that correct
three or four it's called alchemy the
surprising power of ideas that don't
make sense and it's basically a plea for
the world to abandon this need that
everything needs a rational
justification before we
try it in the real world bonk his [ __ ]
works and very logical things fail
fantastic we've just got a fate we've
just got to face up to that well I think
we've got a good list of them that we've
gone through today so hopefully if I can
get a hold of you around about when the
book comes out I'd love to have you back
on again I'm sure that lots of the
listeners will have absolutely enjoyed
today's today's episode I really
appreciate your time it's been a
pleasure speaking to you and next time
you're in London or next time maybe in
Newcastle a lot of these train trips I'd
love to catch up absolutely fantastic
Rory thank you so much for your time
it's been a pleasure thank you very much
[Music]
you